me and him would be eating and there's
like a group of Asian thugs would like
tatted down they got the [__] rat
tails
they're whispering and [__] they keep
looking at us and we're like yo I don't
know who those [__] guys are I don't
recognize them man I think they're we're
gonna get down dude and we're about to
leave right and they're like hey and
we're like hey what's up and then
they're like
and you guys that that Uncle Sam Uncle
Tim
and I'm like oh they're fans they're
just fats
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
the careful boys we are lucky enough to
have with us today Mr Johnny Chang
crazy so like during the break I mean we
just gone back and forth and as things
unfold we're like you know this guy you
know this guy and then yeah I feel so
comfortable with Johnny because he's
just like you mentioned earlier that
dude that we grew up with in sgv you cut
out just a a general idea of who this
guy is yeah yeah yeah it's Johnny
we said that we said you look like an AI
version of everyone we remember oh like
all in one yeah but there is a weird
like familiarity I have with Johnny
where it just feels like the same areas
we know the same streets the same groups
the same gangs like the same people and
that just blows my mind because it's
like almost meeting someone from my past
that I feel like I met before and it's
kind of coming together like
you did this and this oh I heard of you
guys and it's like [__] such a trip
you feel like I've met Joe somewhere
before yeah yeah like for real yeah you
look hella familiar for real yeah I'm
33. and I'm 38 but it's still the same
that she's one generation above
basically you know but and I know all
the guys of his generation that he's
talking about yeah yeah that's crazy bro
because they were the
I mean we're not ogs but they were like
the youngsters that looked it was like
you know we were looking at guys like
let's say if we were 19 right they were
probably in high school
and then we were looking at guys in
their mid-20s as ogs yeah and in the
mid-20s guys we're looking at like the
30s right so like that was that kind of
role where like where like the guys were
like five years younger than us yeah
yeah when you might have met Joe in the
past did he have a pacifier in his mouth
it could have been in a rave bro no that
was that wasn't that life yeah okay that
I was like that was after that life just
trying to jog his memory
just other things did you ever play mama
oh you might have spent too much time
behind the bars to enjoy the festivity
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the Rave era
that kind of died out by the time we
were yeah oh yeah then I got out that
was yeah it was pretty much dead you
know what was interesting to me is like
we were just getting into your
um you're like kind of
touch with God
like you just
it was it was at that point where you
were in your life of like your mom was
telling you yeah we weren't sure you
didn't like the whole Christianity like
Hood hopping whatever it was
and then
um what happened to where you started to
like do it so there was a thing that I
always felt was like this emptiness
inside of my heart right like even when
I was young like joining a gang and
going to prison I thought like oh it's
because I'm in jail that I feel empty
and depressed right
um but when I got out like you know I
had done anger management counseling got
my GED so everything looked like it was
on the up but I had this like void like
this hole in my heart and I it didn't
matter I was I was also selling drugs
and stuff like that trying to make money
and nothing filled that you know and
my mom actually was like oh you have
that emptiness because you don't have
God and I was like Mom like shut up you
know like I was like I didn't want to
hear that right
um but after that happened I had planned
something you know to basically Rob like
a well-known drug dealer in Roland
Heights area where all the rich you know
back then was where all the rich Asians
was at you know Hacienda Roland and um
you know I was supposed to go to like
the ride of this car and then the homie
was supposed to go to the left of the
car but when I went to the right he
stepped in front of me so I just
naturally went to the left and then you
know these three gunshots rang out and I
was like damn I thought my homie was
blasting him actually but he was getting
shot and then the car sped off you know
so he was shooting at your buddy who was
in the driver yeah so they had a dude in
the back in the back seat ready oh like
they knew we were setting up like just
in case I don't think they knew we were
gonna basically Rob him and take all
their their work right but basically
like my homie got shot in the stomach
basically and chest stomach area and
then I remember vividly like the sounds
all of that so basically died in front
of me died you know and then I was like
it was just a mix of emotions I remember
like getting angry like feeling scared
feeling confused and then and then it
hit me like like when I got to the
hospital basically with him uh
essentially like that was supposed to be
me basically oh wow if I was if he
didn't step in front of me I would have
probably I wouldn't be here you know so
from then on I felt that like okay and
and again I brushed it off being you
know a gang member you know you can't
show that right yeah so three days after
that um I get this letter from one of my
homies he was a he was a like a
well-known graffiti artist back then
there used to be tigers and stuff like
that right so he was a really well-known
graffiti artist out out in LA and you
know I grew up with him too and he he
wrote me like this really eerie letter
it was like you know when you go to the
when you you know when you when you're
at in the mountains like think about me
you know I'm always there with you homie
this and I was like what the hell and I
realized it was a suicide letter oh damn
three days after that I found out that
he hung himself in County Jail
so so it was like death death and then
there was another you know shooting that
that happened on the freeway basically
it was like a car to car shooting my
homie was an innocent bystander he was
really young he was like a Young Homie a
little homie he's 17 shot in the head oh
okay so this was all within like a one
week span and so I felt death like what
the heck is going on you know and then
that was on top of my depression and
everything else and my mom was like you
know
you should try coming to church and
again I was like no but her car broke
down and then you know I I wanted to be
good to my mom so this is when you're
out already yeah when I'm out so I took
my mom took her to church and then it
kind of unfolds with the sofa and her
belly story basically wow that's cool
so that's how I kind of fell with God
basically wow what what next after you
found God though like um yeah like what
made you want to also become like a
minister yeah did you begin your own
Ministry no so so I didn't ever want to
become a like I don't think people just
wake up like and be like who lived our
lives and was like you know what I'm
gonna be a pastor today you know like
that doesn't happen right
um I never wanted to go to prisons I
never like I spent all my life after
getting out like I'm never gonna go back
to this place but the pastor at the time
who was kind of like my mentor he
explained to me that there's a lot of
people who felt that emptiness and void
that you felt and like it's a spiritual
aspect of things you know so you gotta
you gotta like go in there and kind of
like lace these people up which means
share with them like your story and
they're gonna it's better than like if
he went in there with the suit nice Cut
like people are not gonna understand
yeah yeah they don't relate exactly so
um I was like but again I had all these
thoughts like bro we don't talk on
camera I don't open you know our culture
is just not like that bro we don't talk
about stuff like this if I was in my
teens and I had someone like you like
talk to me straight about like get the
[__] out of this stupid thing like I
probably would have changed way quicker
yeah but so like versus a square and a
suit that doesn't even know the life
trying to tell you you know what you
gotta change and it's like of course
you're gonna say that you don't know
[__] exactly but you'll listen to some
OG that came out of prison and you're
just like yes sir I [__] up sir
laughs
so when I go to these prisons basically
I talk to these lifers and and you know
just people who are are going through it
you know and and they can relate to
everything even though we're different
races because we have we have like it's
it's not just Christians right in there
there's Buddhists Muslims the one thing
that risks that we're all interconnected
with is the struggle so like they can
understand that like that emptiness that
void like I think a lot of people feel
that especially prisoners you know so
yeah it's it's doing really good you
know they they they like the fact that
I'm there I go every week I go three
times a week basically to different
different prisons Channel Norco
Lancaster you know all these different
spots and um yeah we're just trying to
like help each person one by one that's
tight man I mean someone's got to go out
there and reach out because like it's
just a never-ending pit but you were
inside and you had to like
you know you can't be soft at all and
you kind of have to like create your own
monster did you ever like
um is there any space in your like
bandwidth to make friends or even
connect with anyone else on a human
level at all or it's just always I'm
just gonna be in here and people are
gonna try to kill me I gotta make sure I
have my Garza so when you're in prison
you actually have a lot of surface level
relationships like it's it's all good
you know it but nothing is ever deep
like and and the good thing about prison
was that it made me not from watching so
we had enemies like Asian boys and black
dragon and whoever but when you go in
there you have to drop all of you have
to click up yeah because it's nothing
but Asians exactly so when you go in
there it's there's no more gang banging
there's no more you could have shot at
my homie killed it killed my homie but
we have to be cool because it's like us
against the whole like it's race against
race type yeah you know on that note
which is [__] crazy so um you just
brought back a memory and a rumor where
um
so so our our guys had beef with one of
your other factions not your group
but we heard
um that that group paid your group
to assassinate one of our dudes they
drove up and they shot somebody in front
of my buddy's house which ended up being
a guy from your own Camp you heard about
that yes
so it did happen
uh well okay I don't know so so it
that's that's a oh my God you cleared up
a rumor in my mind that's been in my
head for like ever and so the thing is
that special day we were supposed to
have a rumble and and solve [__] so they
knew we were all at this house
and uh the guys that came which is a
different side fraction of their gang he
didn't even know that this was gonna go
down he was smoking weed at the
doorsteps and when they came up and and
did the drive-by they ended up shooting
their own side damn yeah and it was a it
was a whole [__] mess wow oh [__]
that's crazy damn it's a rumor yeah but
it's a crazy rumor
but
but the thing is
what's crazy is that when you're when
you're in jail when you get older like
all those things it doesn't [__]
matter it just doesn't matter at all you
just it's almost like I feel bad that
everyone had to go through that at that
age and you thought that you were like
in war it's like you're you're like
stupid little soldiers like being told
what to do and by the way we left our
whole group because when that incident
happened our rogs we you know they say
we need some money so we could go get
some straps and retaliate this and that
they took our money and smoked crack
with all of it we didn't get anything we
didn't have anything to protect
ourselves with allegedly right allegedly
so we were like what are we gonna do
like we got abandoned by our own group
and then we started questioning that
whole gang [__] and it was like these
guys aren't our brothers and taking care
of us and like they're not doing [__]
and then they wanted us to put in the
work after you know that thing happened
to us so I was like man I'm in a group
that's just not really taking care of
each other
it's just all talk and and and I think
that was the biggest reality check for
me because I thought we were like I
really believed it like amen like we go
get them back so we're gonna go get you
know what we have to do like we're gonna
get guns and [__] and it didn't happen
I'm like damn
wow that was a crazy uh moment there
yeah so like you also mentioned that
um you know maybe there's like Asian
gangs here Asian gangs here and you guys
are like Rivals and stuff but then
you're going to prison and then it's
like everybody just clicks up because
it's race Wars and stuff
um what happens for example like after
y'all like come back out is it like all
right back to our tribalism and that
type of it's honestly dependent on the
person I mean like you could go back to
gang banging but I mean you broke down
spreads with people you shared like food
with them like you know you guys went a
war together like it's really kind of
looked down upon so like me like I when
I go back I don't have issues with those
people and when I see them I'm like hey
it's all love because even if it's
somebody representing them like I was
locked up with one of their big homies
or whatever it is so you kind of it's
not like you give each other a pass but
like like Joe was saying you just start
to realize like this is all [__]
yeah there's like a there's like a
bigger picture a bigger place exactly
and and I I honestly I tell my homies
all the time I tell everybody like
whoever enemies or whatever I really
wish that it was like this from the jump
like we were we were all cool and we
were just trying to like break bread and
just better Our Lives you know what I
mean versus like running up and shooting
people and doing stuff like that you
know so that and they're like yeah we
agree because it's much more peaceful
it's much more better nowadays you know
like in our era like it was just it was
crazy bro like I always thought too I
was like all right why you have so much
Asian pride but you're just out here
killing other Asians so and then there
there was beef with Mexicans or whatever
little bit but that wasn't the main
enemy the main enemy was
you're like [__] asian brothers and
[__] like from other groups that's what
blew my mind I mean certain areas it was
me it was like you know certain gangs
were really like on that kill Asian type
of thing but for the most part yeah
which I was saying is great yeah because
when you saw
um like Mexican thugs or or black you
didn't really hit them up they you they
were just invisible they're like they're
just doing their thing we're doing our
thing and when you see an Asian kid with
Cortez's on it was on yeah right
remember oh yeah yeah you have Cortez is
okay like what's crazy it's like when
you see it take them off bro it's weird
how you like you like form friendships
because you're like oh he's 18th Street
that's cool but then it's like wait
shouldn't it be like if it was about
your race it would be like no no 18th
Street's not cool no mas is not cool but
it's like you have all these Asian gangs
being cool with all these other Hispanic
gangs but then it's just Asians fighting
Asians and the Hispanics fighting
Hispanics too man but I think that was
really something about the SUV in
general the dynamic is like all hoods if
you notice in our era didn't get along
nobody was cool like whoever the Mexican
hoods like they all beefed it with each
other and then even Asian hoods too like
no I mean dubs were not cool with it
even doves within dubs were not yeah
it's called said tripping we was said
trip and stuff like it's it was crazy
bro and now it's like people are all
like you know Long Beach is like there's
like a lot of clicks where they click up
and then they go against people or they
go with blacks and go against whoever it
was never like that in the same game
you know yeah but I feel like gang
banging was our generation because
before that they were just doing Mafia
stuff yeah that's right and then our
generation wanted to be cooler so I saw
the transition from Asians dressing like
GQ and Hong Kong style and more like
like Mafia style to like looking like
cholos and street thugs and and like our
generation adopted that they did away
with the Dilo Silo system like the you
know because there were Chinese gangs
that were starting to recruit
multiculturally like by my generation it
was mostly Japanese Chinese and
cambodians in in my group and then and
then so they weren't even honoring the
Cantonese system and then we started
changing the names we started using
words like oh that's my OG
and then so I think that's where kind of
yeah yeah for sure and then they weren't
doing the the hitting up and like game
like they were pulling up on people
saying where you from like they're
trying to stay low-key do the extortion
stuff and or you know like they're doing
that stuff
I mean they would get tats but it would
it wouldn't be like me well I would they
would just look at me like you're dumb
you know
blasted and like big old Target on your
back they get mad because they had like
dragons and stuff like Yakuza style
under the suit yeah it's in the shape of
only a t-shirt so the T-shirt
what do you think of uh what do you
think of the responsive we always
wondered about this but like when you
see certain chinatowns and certain like
Asian communities in California when
there's attacks and there's elderly
people getting hurt uh a popular
response to that from our generations to
be like oh man when if Asian gangs were
active it wouldn't happen as easily do
you think that's true I think um
I think so in certain areas honestly
because although we fought a lot like
kind of Joe was mentioning I had a lot
of issues with Hispanics when I was
growing up just in my area and
um a lot of the work we put in kind of
made them realize that we can't do this
to these people you know what I mean
like even though we we fought each other
as well but it kind of set the trend
that like okay we can't beat up on
grandmas and Rob you know what I mean
and that kind of set the tone for for
them you know and I feel like it's the
same way like if there was let's say
that like Our Generations they just went
back to that and it was like in Oakland
or whatever I don't think they would be
that yeah like you know what I mean like
I think we would band together and
actually you know do something about it
but again we also it's it's hard to say
that because I could play the other side
of the fence too like we also would do
home invasion robberies on ourselves
like so it's it's really hard to say but
personally like from just speaking from
my my experience the type of person that
I am that's how I would I would
what people don't know about that era is
like if they didn't recognize you in the
neighborhood and you're just walking
around with a basketball just minding
your own business three four guys are
going to walk up to you and ask you
where you're from and stuff and if
you're not from that area they don't
recognize you some even if you say like
I'm not a gangster whatever don't just
beat you for fun so that was why people
just stayed in their own communities
like people didn't go out and I think
that was Chinatown like I remember
Chinatown was like actually they had
gangs but they were hidden like they
were like chilling and then like if
someone caused the Ruckus out of shop an
old man would pop out and he's armed or
like whatever yeah yeah but like now
it's not like that it's just a safe
tourist place and security guards or a
bunch of kids that come out and jump the
[__] out of whatever is causing trouble
yeah yeah but it's not like that no more
that's another uh another question that
we kind of run into a lot as well as
like since you still live in this area
um we were talking about how back in the
day it was like you couldn't I can't
remember being able to just walk around
and pass a group of other Asians that I
didn't know without them [__] with me
in some way like they would just I just
wanted to get some boba dude yeah they
would just have something to say like no
matter what yeah but like and I was
trying to ask some young people that
live in the sgv now like does that
happen to you and some of them say yeah
like that happens but then what that
they're still Asian gangs yeah some of
them say that that's not even gangs it's
just people like bowling not even yeah
they're not they're not banging banging
or anything they're just like
you know just to punk them but like I
don't I don't see that really anymore
yeah yeah I don't see that back then
yeah like you said it you would have to
like walk around like we would fight
like even when like kids would fight
when they're not even from gangs yeah
people would just roll up on them like
I've seen kids who would go to like like
Alhambra high school or something and
they would just get beat up like on on
Third Street or whatever and they're not
even gang members they play basketball
yeah you know like and so yeah I but I
don't see that honestly I don't see that
around I don't even hear that really
happening like that yeah maybe it's more
of like a school thing or like a yeah
there were even non-gangsters that loved
just fist fight yeah exactly like they
would go to different schools just to
look for someone a fist fight with yeah
it was a I just think it was a different
time with like more aggression
because now people bring it back yeah
it's not just that too I remember like
when meth hit like there was a point
where I don't know if you guys remember
that but every they would have like
groups of people and just like passing
pookies around you know and they were
and that really messed up a lot it
cracked out a lot of people it made
Armani the way that it was you know what
I mean like and it just everyone was
just crazy after that because they were
actually basically come either on the
come down or you know or like that so
people don't realize that but that that
hit the SUV hard I didn't think about
that um damn dude that's crazy
um
one thing you know is just talking to
you just feels like a different life but
it's just all these emotions and
memories coming back but I think um you
might relate with this but like when you
get out or like just
when people are looking at you and
you're at a cafe
I used to get those feelings of like who
are they
what do they want
but did they come up to you and say can
I get a picture because I saw you on
Spotify it happens all the time right
yeah that was you know where JJ's is at
right me and him would be eating and it
was like a group of Asian thugs with
like tatted down they got the [__]
rat tails
they're whispering and [__] they keep
looking at us and we're like yo I don't
know who those [__] guys are I don't
recognize them man I think they're we're
gonna get down dude I just want to go to
elac and [__] bro I don't want to fight
no more and then we we get up and we're
like and we're about to leave right and
they're like hey and we're like hey
what's up another light
are you guys that that Uncle Sam Uncle
Jim
and I'm like oh they're fans they're
just
remember that dude
bro do you get do you get that kind of
feeling still yeah oh man I don't get
scared you know you have like we're
observing naturally living that
lifestyle so I'll see people stare at me
like Double Take and I'm like please God
no it's gonna be like you know what I
mean today there's like a layer of I
think like PTSD that doesn't go away at
the show yeah can I have a photo yeah
they're like are you here are you a
Johnny yeah I'm like I sometimes I just
want to [__] with them like no
okay now my homie who doesn't look like
me like that's Johnny right there
foreign